we can handle a cat no not this one look
at that hair's Fuller baby that cat
looks way better than that dog
it's that whole store in the background
is a giant Tile World is it like a
panorama very high resolution panorama
so you worked on Green Lantern yeah
Green Lantern
is
um
greenlander is a movie that we looked up
to
oh
the best people
responds oh hey guys I'm Jordan and I'm
here to talk to you about our sponsor
today Bessie
the weather in La has been super
indecisive lately thunderstorms almost
every single day literally our streets
for lunch it's like an ocean this is
literally what it looks like yesterday I
couldn't even walk into the office but
today it's a game changer I have on
betsies so I'm prepared for anything
just watch this dude you should have put
on besties all of Bessie's shoes are 100
waterproof plus they're comfortable and
stylish sneakers that you can wear every
day there's so many more Styles
including the new storm bursts the new
storm burst hiking boots are super
grippy and warm they even added an extra
lug rubber outsole that gives extra grip
and slippier wetter conditions one of my
favorite things about all Bessie shoes
is that they're 100 vegan they even use
way less waste materials than other
sneaker Brands oh do my rain dance I do
my rain dance oh oh oh yeah there's a
whole react episode that's happening
right now so do me a favor if you want
to go outside and do your rain dance as
well go to bessie.com put in the code
cold our crew to get 15 off your entire
purchase do young rain dance
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we have a very special guest on the
couch today Aaron Estrada from crafty
Apes welcome nice to be here Jordan
Allen's here hey always an honor how are
you Erin tell us a little bit about
yourself okay well I'm a visual effects
artist I've got at this point over 25
years experience in the business pretty
much did everything the hard way I
started started at the bottom and worked
my way all the way up through the ranks
and that's how I finally ended up to be
like a head of Studio when I got my
first breaks in the industry was working
on TV computer animation for cartoons
and that segued into features cartoons
as well do you get your hands dirty
still oh yeah I mean and actually one of
my favorite parts of working as a visual
effects supervisor is I get to see the
entire life cycle of shots I get to go
from like onset shooting the plates all
the way to sometimes even doing the
shots myself sweet well let's take a
look at some clips here
Jimmy Neutron Nicktoon blast oh my gosh
Jimmy Neutron
it was a ride simulator at Universal oh
it replaced the Scooby-Doo one oh CB
writing on it yes
a lot going into this yeah there's a lot
going into this my goodness yeah how
many cuts are there like how many how
many stitches there's a lot of yeah
invisible stitches and fake cuts and
this is an interesting one too because
yeah you have to create this giant long
motion path and you have to maintain the
same velocity basically so it's just
actually a relatively simple thing and
yet it's something you still have to
think about and yeah you can just use
like a simple expression to just like
blend two motion paths together and get
the velocity at least lined up so that
the invisible cut works
that light tunnel was a situation where
it was like you can't use Ray tracing
it's too expensive I'm like you can't
not use Ray tracing in this situation
it's just to be dumb literally a cloud
of actual physical Point lights and it's
only like a moment and as it turned out
it wasn't too expensive Ray tracing for
people who don't know is uh essentially
you're you're reversing the way that the
eye works right a source of light take
the Sun for example will bounce around
on everything and eventually hit our
retinas but Ray tracing reverses that
process we're shooting through the image
plane from the camera for each pixel
right and that is bouncing around our
scene and eventually finding the source
of the light and that way we know
exactly where that light Ray was what it
bounced off the reflectance the perfect
refraction all that stuff and we're
given a very realistic rendition of what
the scene should look like based on
realistic right perfect description of
it so yeah renders have gotten much more
accurate now that we have physically
accurate shading and lighting models
they've also become like vastly more
computationally intensive but we have
more compute power so we might as well
use it obviously you were a render
specialist you are a render specialist
and you have a wealth of experience with
how how this technology has so
dramatically evolved Computing Powers
evolved and this is kind of a famous
comparison that I've seen quite a bit
and I think it perfectly encapsulates
how far we've come in such a short
amount of time but it's Toy Story the
dog from 1995 versus the cat from 2019
in Toy Story 4. breaking down these two
images what are the biggest advancements
that we've had to get from that to that
inside of you know 20 what 24 years 25
years so they're using Shadow maps for
the Toy Story stuff they would have had
Ray Trace Shadows but not in render man
there's other software that was doing a
render man where it really wasn't doing
it at that point so in order to create
Shadows what you would essentially do is
you'd render another camera from where
the light was that's called The Shadow
map so it's just basically a depth map
from the position of where the light was
that determines is the thing in the
light or is it in Shadow because if it
can't see the object then clearly it's
obscured by something and therefore in
Shadow but now we kind of take for
granted that this like with a global
illumination render that the Shadows are
going to have the right amount of
density relative to the ambient in the
scene that's just not how it worked back
then right when they run down the
hallway into the room you can see their
Shadows on top of the Shadow
obviously they wouldn't have been using
subdes yet even though it would have
been around the time that they were
inventing them what's a sub D
subdivision surface yes Subdivision
Services are great because they have all
the advantages of polygons it's a
continuous manifold surface of polygons
that you then just subdivide a whole
bunch of times subdivision is basically
Uprising it and you'll see that a lot
with displacement mapping too where if
you're adding a displacement map to
actually deform the surface of the
geometry but the geometry isn't like
dense enough with polygons to look good
a lot of renders come render time can
actually do that subdividing to give it
the detail required in the actual
polygonal form to have like a nice look
of deformed rocks or stones or whatever
you need really crazy things are kind of
seeing this happen now in real time with
the nanite engine from unreal exactly we
just hold it in a super super dense mesh
and then it de-reses that mesh
subdivides it
so it's in every polygon is a pixel and
as it goes away from you it's like oh I
can make the polygons bigger to stop me
a pixel as it comes closer I'll just
subdivide it so they're smaller to be a
pixel well that's the thing right it's
all about optimization and like memory
storage and and being optimal with that
so with like the nanite stuff that just
blows me away it's continually
optimizing itself so there's not wasting
any energy on areas that aren't required
you know it's crazy seeing this effort I
haven't watched Toy Story in a long time
but like even just like the seams of the
texture not lining up on some of the
corners of the wallpaper yeah and this
movie is interesting because there were
a lot of limitations at the time
obviously it's the first a 3D animated
motion picture they had to hide certain
things like uh with the adults they
wouldn't like them fully sometimes to
avoid like the missing elements that
would make a human feel like a human The
Uncanny Valley The Uncanny Valley so
they try to frame it in such a way like
this is a really cool scene because a
lot of the coverage of the people is
just like their ankles and stuff yeah
from the views of the toys and so you
know it's the same thing that comes up
over and over again where creativity
really thrives when it's put in a box
and here it was totally put in a box
where was like we can't do this this and
this so you have to find a storytelling
way to make that make sense like just
show her feet right there there you go
we don't need to worry about all the
full facial animation and the stuff
that's that's challenging for us her
cabinet is surrounded by a moat of
exposed aisle where Dragon roams
we got all the tricks of the training
what do you wash on the ground
that cat looks way better than that dog
the plastic looks better because it's
got a little bit of subsurface and well
peeps porcelain looks more like
physically solid and let's talk about a
situation like this where it's like got
Global illumination Global illumination
is essentially it's the bounce light in
your scene it's you know if I'm standing
near this uh this green wall here the
light that bounces off that will bounce
onto me and it's it's keeping track of
all of those those bounce Light Elements
you might be tempted to pump up a light
source well that would actually change
the ambient yeah and so you're breaking
that mathematical relationship a subtle
adjustment you might get away with
because it's like changing the ratio in
your lighting setup right it's like oh I
didn't put as much fill on it and I
pumped up the key a little bit more or
something like that what did I say
Eileen you so when you're watching these
shots I want you to pick one thing
what's one thing that stands out to you
is just being like wow everything has
been plused up here the textures are
better the lighting is better so it's
like if I had to pick just one thing
that would move the needle it would be
the lighting how often in these kinds of
renders are they rendering without
motion blur too because I know it's very
taxing obviously to render it's been a
while since we did that like if
DreamWorks our early stuff when I first
got there their render it could do 3D
motion blur but was considered too
expensive so we would use a vector based
motion blur after rendering without
motion blur and then we would apply
motion blur as a post process and their
post-process motion blur is pretty slick
because it actually had a way of doing
like crack filling so if you had like an
occlusion it knew how to fill that crack
oh interesting yeah and motion vectors
too are very interesting in that it's
essentially like a colored map that is
measuring the vector changes for each
point right over time every single frame
basically telling whatever is applying
the motion blur how these points are
moving frame by frame and it's using
that information and then generating a
faux motion blur on the back end that's
a lot lighter weight you don't have to
worry about rendering with motion blur
and all the time that that takes but of
course there's limitations there right
it's an interesting science and I kicked
myself for not paying more attention to
math class because now I use it all the
time and yeah
yeah what
Woody
you did all you could
time to go home and that's gonna be a
tough thing to do as like an art
director on this be like all right Buzz
and Woody still need to look like Buzz
and Woody yeah from when our computers
were potatoes but we don't want to make
everything look like potatoes so what do
we do what's really interesting about
this is that like you said things are
way more render intensive now than they
were back then the worst frames
typically it was a range of one hour to
30 hours to render a single frame that
now supposedly could just be rendered
before you even done watching it the
whole film could be done it's really
crazy how exponentially we're improving
yeah we're spoiled now now that we have
like the super commoditized gpus that
are supported by the gamers and all the
Deep learning stuff supporting their r d
at Nvidia and also AMD it's like we
benefit from that right like that
competition for that market well that's
why I think fortnite for making unreal
free yeah seriously I will never hate on
fortnite for that reason the reason we
get to use quicksole Mega scans is
because of fortnite thank you foreign
thank you all the teenagers out there
playing fortnite because because of you
we have so many nice tools at our
disposal now
we should put them in the credits of son
of a dungeon
Aaron what movie in your opinion has the
greatest visual effects oh geez best
visual effects in like to the moment
like right now well Avatar which is
probably going to crush all of the
Avatar 2. yep all right so that's a
great answer Avatar Two probably would
have been my answer as well but I want
to hear what movie you think has the
best visual effects of all time the one
that hit you the hardest so if you
wouldn't mind leaving a comment down
below it's great resources for us to dig
into research and give you some good
nuggets of knowledge I feel like we're
going to get a lot of Avatar 2 comments
we already made the episode
the guy was here
I guess the only person we could have on
is Jim Cameron uh can I call him Jim yet
or do I need me to press
Darwin status report so this is g-force
which are talking guinea pigs I've
always wanted to be in these pitch
meetings just to hear like hear the
pitch for it like guinea pigs butt their
secret agents it's like how does this
get somebody like all right yeah
Millions I'll give you millions of
dollars thousands of people to achieve
this oh it's not a secret hoytman who
directed it his son just pitched it his
child said they had a guinea pig and he
thought it was cool and it made him into
secret agents and they just made a movie
around it I actually kind of love that
yeah that's great the sequence I worked
on a lot was the one where they're in
the terrarium
[Music]
why did you just do that I thought it
might cheer us up so the people don't
see them having a conversation in the
yeah and the normal people They have the
Spy people they work with and this is
obviously different than the stuff we've
seen so far because it's a mix of the
live action and the CG yeah you know
when it comes to lighting this stuff do
you feel like you're more in a box
because obviously you have to match
exactly what was on set that's an
interesting question because like
working on cartoons I started to feel
like it was a little bit like assembly
line so even though you have to match a
plate to me at the time it felt more
novel and more like every mission was a
little more unique and it was my
responsibility to either come up with a
look or match a leads look so when I'm
saying we're matching a plate in this
case there is no plate these are pretty
much full CG shots we're matching the
look of the rest of the show and then in
shots where there's a plate obviously
we're matching the CG to the plate
all I'm saying is know your place behind
this line what's cool about this
sequence is that whole pet store in the
background is a giant Tile World it's a
tile world yeah is that like a panorama
very high resolution Panorama tile I
like that tile World Tile World that's
epic and I guess the difference between
Tile World and just a panorama I would
say the distinction is that all the
pieces of the Panorama move so like each
tile is a motion picture oh interesting
so they're getting video like I'm gonna
film this wall for a while I'm gonna
film this wall for a while because it's
all populated with animals oh wow and
since animals like as everybody knows
they're kind of hard to work with so and
and there's all these rules like you
can't keep them on set for too long you
don't you just can't stress them out so
they just dress the whole pet shop with
the animals and had a day where they
could do the tile and then they never
have to keep the animals there for a
bunch of stuff and then for when we're
rendering this stuff we could just
essentially recreate any angle that we
needed to recreate by just pointing the
CG camera in the right direction and we
had the right piece of pet shop and we
could fix the continuity so that this
essentially was sequentially the right
part of time so if an animal you
wouldn't see an animal move the same way
like twice in the background so in a way
you're not really you're not as much
trying to put CG into a real plate
instead you've taken these pictures or
these videos of real life elements and
built a whole environment out of that so
you're basically you're basically living
in a full CG scene but to us it looks
like it's a composite right right very
cool but we could also use it in the CG
render to create things like reflection
Maps but yeah I like that little like
little water bottle feeder uh
love this Melanie Palm in the morning
what kind of assets would you be getting
from the onset supervisor that helped
make your job lighting a lot easier when
it comes to matching the physical lights
on set so this film was really well
looked at and really well planned in
terms of the onset stuff we weren't
really using hdrs for a lot of stuff it
was still a pretty traditional pipeline
a good camera team should actually
collect most of the camera data for you
you should have the lens you should have
the stop they'll put the shutter speed
in the global notes for the day unless
it's special so you'll know that they're
kind of typical shutter angle that
they're using for the show the iso of
the camera that they have a lot of that
stuff can just be extracted sometimes
from a traditional camera report but
when you're getting into visual effects
you might want to add additional stuff
you might want to get the height of the
camera off the ground the tilt of the
camera what's called a baseline survey
which is like where is the camera
sitting in the scene relative to the
scene depending on how complex the scene
is you might actually order a lidar scan
and get like a to the millimeter like
sub millimeter scan of the physical
space you might actually order a huge
amount of texture collection associated
with that scan and if you you have a
data if you have a data Wrangler on set
and you don't have an actual like an
experience on setup could make that call
on the day right there you've got to
make sure you order that properly and
instruct them okay this is the depth of
the package I need you to put together
for this wow you know you just got a VFX
uh Supervision masterclass in like four
sentences thanks to Aaron there that's
awesome Michael I'm talking to you if
you're not subscribed subscribe now all
you mics out there you can be lumped
into that as well because you feel like
it but this is for the Michaels the
formal ones
the formal ones the artist formerly
known as Michael
Mike the artist normally known as Mike
Michael
so you mentioned that you actually
you've taught visual effects yeah you
actually have resources online for
people who want to learn visual effects
right that's correct so you have a
website yep learn vfx.com it's nuke
lessons right now and a little bit of
moto but I'm mostly focused on
compositing because that's what I've
shifted my career to recently so nice
and as well as a YouTube channel yes
learn the effects.com
no not all right and you got some free
lessons up there as well yes that's
where I dropped my free licenses on the
YouTube channel heck yeah okay put links
in the description below for those of
you out there who want to check it out
so you worked on Green Lantern yeah so
Green Lantern
is
um Green Lantern is a movie that we
looked to
it's got some rough stuff in it a lot of
the thoughts around Green Lantern can be
summarized in the perfect metaphor of
his mask so they did the mask CG on his
face now the faces are very hard to do
and they move all over the place
especially when people are emoting like
actors and so to try to stick a CG thing
onto somebody's skin and make it feel
like it's embedded and actually part of
the shot especially when the actor is
not wearing it and it would influence
her performance you're setting yourself
up for a whole world of hurt and that's
the world that I guess you got to live
in for a little while
one at the mass
going into principal photography or was
that something that was kind of thrown
on the back end I'm assuming that they
did I'm not sure I knew that yet until I
saw one show up in my shot because he
does a lot of acting without the mask on
but then when he goes into action he
puts the mask on and yeah like Nico said
It's tricky to track a face and
especially when the head's moving around
this much we had a full digidouble of
him so match moving his head his body
every single no even I think you
probably aren't thinking about this much
but his hands are being tracked too
a lot of artists having to sit there and
like Trace effectively Ron Reynolds
movement which in my mind you start to
lose a little bit of the whole purpose
of having an artist there in the first
place you're just going to literally
exactly pixel match the other person
it's like you're just a machine at that
point I mean I yeah I don't imagine
anyone got into VFX to be able to
perfectly describe Ryan Reynolds body
after four months of just painstakingly
match moving it but look at his physique
he could have just had a suit on yeah
slip him into some latex and call it a
day yeah
oh green this is probably the best the
suit ever looks is this scene here
because this got workshopped a lot to
kind of come up with the look of it they
wanted to do the CG from the start
because they knew there was going to be
all this energy like flowing through it
and the soup was supposed to have sort
of like a gel like feeling like
refractive feeling over him and it had
really complicated layered shaders and
stuff and then there was a whole big
system of aovs is a great example of
aov's just Madness for this one to
achieve all the glows and stuff when he
really activates it it like it's more
intense and let the energy traces over
and not just like the energy flowing
through the little like cracks in the
suit but like it starts to pop off like
like little lightning bolts so there was
a whole effects simulation pass that
would like kick off that geometry
necessary to make those little lightning
bolts like Chase along is it that much
harder because it's all skin tight you
know like as opposed to Iron Man is is
kind of a looser rigid structure and
this is like very organic and skin like
and where it has to touch his skin it
has to not feel like it's sliding yeah
and that was all always kind of tricky
on the shots I was doing the collar was
always the tricky thing because the suit
itself it's like you basically could
paint his body away if it wasn't working
perfectly not to mention like save a
mask on his face so now you need to have
little Shadows cast on his face and it's
not really doing that and his face is
picking up light as if there's nothing
there and it's not deforming yeah when
things don't meet expectations uh it's
because you didn't have a lot of time or
there wasn't a lot of planning up front
but it's always it's always boils down
to a lack of time at the end of the day
a lack of planning is due to a lack of
time I would say if you if you're doing
a visual effects film try to get your
visual effects expert involved as early
as possible yes like a consultant or
somebody because that will help answer a
lot of your questions and then keep that
train from being derailed before it gets
out of the station that's why I'm
fascinated by the virtual production
stuff and volumes and how it's shifting
so much of post to pre where it's done
and the producers are seeing it in
camera director seeing it in camera and
it's already committed it's kind of like
a weight off the shoulder there's a
visual effects going all right we're
done it's in the can unless of course
they want to Roto everybody and switch
everything around which is still
possible I suppose Green Lantern was an
unfun show to work on it was just like
at the end seeing the audience reception
wasn't good and only the screenings and
it's like oh this story was a little
soft you know it's like nobody ever sets
out to make a film that isn't like
awesome yeah but and so it's like have
everybody be hating on it's like uh and
this show had some really it's had some
really interesting stuff going on like
even that glowing thing on his chest
it's kind of like volumetric I mean all
these like interesting neat things that
were going on that was like I never had
the opportunity to make like a
volumetric path Trace thing in a dude's
chest before and one of the things I
love about this business is that you
have to be the kind of person that likes
learning stuff
every single job you will be stretching
and learning new things so if that's not
your character then you probably
shouldn't get into this
but that's also what's great because
it's never boring there's always
something new to learn nice little
positive ending right there I like it a
lot thank you everybody for watching I
hope you enjoyed your Saturday or Friday
if you're watching on the website a
extended cuts are there you know how to
find them
Aaron thanks so much for joining us on
the couch it's been awesome yes
so much fun guys yeah well good luck on
your walk back to New Mexico it's gonna
take a while
so long everybody